there are many powerful an iconic gods
and goddesses in Greek mythology but
sadly they tend to hog the limelight and
stories of the lesser gods and deities
are sometimes swept under the rug and
almost forgotten a good example of this
is pan the god of the wild he frequently
features in literature and artwork but
he's not considered one of the major
gods of ancient Greece some of you may
even be more familiar with the creature
from the film Pan's Labyrinth than pans
depictions in Greek mythology
although the creature in the movie is
not pan their appearances are similar it
could be pans association with nature
and wildlife but cause his appearance to
differ from the other gods his upper
body was just like that of a man but he
also had the lower half of a goat along
with horns a combination that we've now
come to refer to as a form there are
many who consider pan to be one of the
oldest gods in Greek mythology his
association with nature wooded areas and
pasture lands is where his name is
derived from panels first worshipped in
the rustic rural areas far from the
large populated cities meaning that
there were no large temples or monuments
built to worship Him the worship of pan
instead took place in nature commonly in
caves and grottoes with his most avid
followers been shepherds and hunters it
was pretty common place for shepherds
and herdsmen to sacrifice a portion of
their cattle in the name of pan when it
came to offerings made in his name pan
enjoyed vases and all kinds of pottery
but it was known that he had a
particular taste for grasshoppers coated
in gold
the exact lineage of pan is uncertain
with some accounts of him being the son
of Hermes and others claiming that he
was the son of Zeus in some stories his
mother was Penelope wife to the hero
Odysseus despite the identity of his
parents being a mystery the story of
pans birth remains the same when pan was
born his mother was so distressed by his
unusual appearance that she ran away
abandoning pan he was later found and
taken to Mount Olympus where he would
become a favorite of the Gods like many
of the other gods and goddesses pan had
a host of attributes that set him apart
from human beings he was capable of
running long distances in a short period
of time without suffering fatigue and in
some accounts he could even teleport
himself to Mount Olympus and back he
also possessed him and strength and was
immortal Pan is quite often depicted as
having a playful and almost trickster
like sense of humor and that coupled
with his ability to transform objects
into different forms meant that he would
often entertain himself with mischievous
schemes and plans when he wasn't up to
no good pan would spend the rest of his
time chasing the nymphs through the
forest attempting to seduce them they
would often flee because of his
unconventional appearance and in many of
the old stories pan was considered to be
rather ugly there is a story about a
particular wood nymph that pan took a
liking to because she was the most
beautiful in all the forest she rejected
all of pans advances and took refuge
among her sisters who transformed her
into a reed unsure which read she had
been transformed into pan took a handful
of them each of different sized and
joined them together he began to blow
produce in a melody that captivated all
around him and thus the pan flute was
created forever named after its creator
he was considered to have an affinity
for music and was often shown alongside
his instrument
Pan was a frequent companion to Dionysus
the god of wine with wine and the music
going hand-in-hand these two were
essentially ancient drinking buddies the
word panic is believed to have derived
from pan his menacing voice frightened
anyone who was unfortunate enough to
stumble upon him there is a tale of war
where a hold of giants marched upon
Mount Olympus and the gods it is said
that Pan shout was so overwhelming that
when they heard it the Giants began to
panic and flee a din the gods in their
eventual victory over the years Pan has
been a symbol of nature in the wild the
ancient mystery of the forest he shows
no interest in accumulating power like
many of the other gods instead he is a
free-spirited individual boisterous and
lustful and he'd rather partake in
activities that we expect from humans
listening to music drinking wine and
just having a good time there is no
doubt that Pan is an entertaining
character and much like nature he's
unpredictable and at times frightening
which is what makes him so interesting I
hope you guys enjoyed today's video if
you did then please go ahead and give it
a like because it helps a lot but as
always I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained wishing everyone a
happy holiday